louis saillants et un ex commandos
marine
il nous emmène dans les coulisses de la
guerre contre le djihadisme au sahel
l'ennemi l'abord est parfaitement
légitime qu'on parle de djihadistes on
parle de gens qui recrutent des enfants
on parle de gens qui sont d'une barbarie
extrême cerexhe d'un terreau qui peut
favoriser l'extension du terrorisme ne
faut pas imaginer qu'il suffit
simplement d'avoir un pays pauvre pour
que l'islam c'est un oubli un mac sont
embrigadés ils ont été séduits ils ont
été manipulés et d'autres qui agissent
de manière parfaitement confiante
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue pour deux
heures d'émission nous décrypterons
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités et nos reporters sur le terrain
tout de suite voici les grands titres de
l'actualité de ce lundi 8 mars alors que
les hôpitaux d'île de france doivent des
programmes et 40 % de leur activité pour
augmenter de 500 places le nombre de
lits de réanimation dédiée aux malades
du code vide
sur le front des vaccins la livraison
ont donné en priorité aux pharmaciens
cette semaine au détriment des médecins
généralistes qui crient au scandale
les centres de vaccination s'ouvre
malgré le manque de vaccins outre
atlantique un procès attendu à
minneapolis finalement reporté celui de
derek à shawville le policier accusé
d'avoir tué jojoy le 25 mai dernier
après l'avoir plaquée au sol est
maintenue pendant près de neuf minutes
un supplice filmé par une passante dont
les images ont fait le tour du monde
une étape judiciaire symbolique dans un
pays marqué par de fortes tensions
raciales
[Musique]
tant birmanie le bras de fer se poursuit
multiples rassemblements dans tout le
pays et appelle à la grève générale
les principaux syndicats veulent
l'intensifier pour étouffer l'économie
et faire pression sur la junte
cette dernière elle met en garde les
fonctionnaires qui n'auront pas repris
le travail sans licencier
[Musique]
cinq cent mille cinq cent mille 85000
français vaccinés au cours du week-end
dernier le gouvernement veut montrer
qu'il accélère dans sa campagne de
vaccination et revoit sa stratégie
depuis vendredi les pharmaciens les
sages-femmes et les infirmiers peuvent à
leur tour administrer les doses les
explications de nicolas petit pour
espérer comme il l'a évoqué un possible
retour à la normale à la mi avril le
gouvernement a décidé de prendre de
nouvelles dispositions
quitte à revoir sa variable d'ajustement
alors que le premier ministre jean
castex avait déclaré jeudi dernier lors
de sa conférence de presse hebdomadaire
que la vaccination en pharmacie
débuterait à compter de la semaine du 15
mars
un décret a été publié au journal
officiel le lendemain et permet depuis
aux pharmaciens mais aussi aux sages
femmes et aux infirmiers de vacciner un
élargissement anticipée du personnel
autorisé à administrer des vaccins qui
devraient répondre à l'accélération des
livraisons de doses annoncée ce lundi
par la ministre délégué chargé de
l'industrie a nié ce panier une hache et
vous avez plus d'un million cinq cent
mille doses qui sont livrés chaque
semaine et nous allons passer le cap des
deux millions de doses livrées chaque
semaine d'ici deux semaines
nous avons une augmentation des
livraisons du vaccin biotech feather le
vaccin moderne est en train de monter en
capacité et le vaccin astrazeneca même
sur un plateau et du côté de 4 millions
de livraisons par mois on est en
capacité de vacciner 30 millions de
français d'ici la fin du mois de juin
nous avons les doses pour se faire un
gouvernement qui se veut optimiste
malgré les couacs
il est 22h30 dimanche soir lorsque la
direction générale de la santé envoie ce
message en urgence aux pharmaciens et
médecins à propos des commandes de
vaccins
à noter que pour la semaine du 8 mars la
commande ne sera ouverte que pour les
besoins propres des officines il ne sera
pas possible de prendre des commandes
pour les médecins compte tenu du nombre
de doses livrées par astrazeneca
un message qui a eu l'effet d'une bombe
auprès des généralistes habilité à
injecter le vaccin
astrazeneca aux personnes âgées de 50 à
75 ans avec des comorbidités depuis le
25 février
ces derniers ont fait part de leurs
compréhension les conneries continue on
ouvre aux pharmaciens mais on ferme
provisoirement au médecin quel est
l'esprit malade qui prend ce genre de
décisions alors là les bras m'en tombent
on va donc permettre les vaccins chez le
pharmacien comment en ne livrant aucune
dose chez les médecins
l'incompréhension est d'autant plus
forte que bon nombre de médecins avaient
ce week end accepté de donner de leur
temps pour vacciner dans les centres
ouverts à l'occasion d'une opération
coup de poing du gouvernement ne voulons
pas entendre parler d vaccinodromes en
janvier préférant miser sur la proximité
l'exécutif a pourtant grâce à eux pu
atteindre les 585 milles français
vaccinés au cours du week end
reste à savoir si les généralistes
seront toujours aussi généreux dans les
prochaines semaines les priorités donc
aux données aux pharmaciens de cette
semaine pour commander des doses de
vaccins une annonce qui fait suite à
l'ouverture de la vaccination en
officine à partir de la semaine du 15
mars les médecins généralistes devront
donc patienter alors qu'ils vaccinent en
cabinet depuis le 25 février
ils devront réduire ainsi la cadence
alors confie non nous à l'absurde avec
ce nouveau tournant pris par la campagne
vaccinale française c'est l'objet de
notre décryptage ce soir pour en parler
nous sommes avec jérôme marty médecin
généraliste président de l'union
française pour une médecine libre
bonsoir jérôme marty merci d'être avec
nous à vos côtés denis millet pharmacien
à 90 coprésident du fspf en loire
atlantique à la fédération des syndicats
pharmaceutiques de france bonsoir à tous
les deux merci d'être avec nous alors
c'est la polémique 1 depuis maintenant
trois jours les doses de vaccins qui
sont réorientés vers les pharmacies les
médecins généralistes
on l'a constaté tout au long de la
journée très remonté je me repose avant
de vous faire réagir de regarder le
communiqué du syndicat mg france qui
réclame la démission rien qu'ça du
directeur général de la santé géromin
celle où l'on a noté que pour la semaine
du 8 mars
la commande ne sera ouverte que pour les
besoins propres des officines il ne sera
pas possible de prendre des commandes
pour les médecins compte tenu du nombre
de doses livrées par astrazeneca
ainsi la direction générale de la santé
et particulièrement son directeur jérôme
salomon et si nécessaire de détourner
les doses prévues pour les généralistes
vers les pharmacies
cette décision si elle devait être
confirmée entraîneur et la nécessité de
décommander tous les rendez vous prévus
dans les cabinets mais jérôme marty est
ce que vous partagez cette colère de
l'ue fml gérons salomon doit partir non
mais j'avais la pole et on la partage
bien évidemment après on va pas demander
le départ de jérôme salle au monde
puisque nous ce départ le demande depuis
le mois de mai avril 2000 devait pas
revenir dessus ça fait très longtemps on
demande à ce que cet homme quitte ses
fonctions parce qu'il n'est pas digne
on va pas revenir dessus sur la
problématique ce qu'il faut voir c'est
que tout le monde s'est enflammée moi le
premier puisque je fais partie des gens
qui veulent s
alerte dès hier soir à 23h30 par le
biais de tweets de vidéos
la phrase était mal tourné la plupart de
mes confrères ont compris je relis la
phrase très rapide
à noter comme pour la semaine du 8 mars
la commande ne sera ouverte que pour les
besoins propres des officines et en gras
il est écrit ne sera pas possible de
prendre des commandes pour les mecs est
ce ne sont pas les médecins qui ne
peuvent pas prendre des commandes
vis-à-vis des aux pharmacies mais ce
sont les pharmacies qui ne peuvent pas
prendre des commandes à leurs grossistes
répartiteurs pour les médecins c'est
comme ça qu'il faut le voir
donc les médecins ne vont pas être en
manque de vaccins cette semaine par
contre il peut y avoir une réduction
d'un coupure en quelque sorte du flux
vaccinale et du matériel vaccinal l'on
doit recevoir dans les semaines qui
viennent du fait de ce trou de commandes
qui lie à passer par nos collègues
pharmaciens qui dans la semaine du 8 ne
peuvent en quelque sorte passé commande
que pour leurs officines et pas pour les
médecins c'est là qu'est la
problématique et c'est ça qu'il faut
éviter à tout crin savons ça revient en
fait c'est consensus à peu près la même
chose c'est-à-dire que le commandement
la direction générale de la santé en
quelque sorte déshabille pierre pour
habiller paul
alors que si l'on veut fonctionner de
concert et fonctionnel bien il faut que
les pharmaciens et les médecins
travaillent ensemble dans un range de
frau il n'est pas question de
privilégier le les doses de vaccin si
détourner des généralistes vers les
pharmacies vous votre analyse denis
millet est ce qu on est justement en
train de montrer
deux propositions l'une contre l'autre
enfin on n'essaie pas de les monter
d'une contrôle je pense que le ministère
j'ai vu tellement de la journée parce
que là c'est un peu édulcorée mais enfin
on a quand même vu beaucoup de bisbilles
entre les deux professions des médecins
vraiment très en colère qui ont dû
annuler des des rendez-vous que voilà
qui inclut un peu les pharmaciens de
sept plans d'avoir obtenu gain de cause
il ya eu quand même ça peut être pas ici
mais il ya eu ce genre de propos tout au
long de la journée quand même on a le
projet qu'on avait beaucoup des changes
moi je suis sur plusieurs réseaux en
actions de vue beaucoup des changes
d'antan ce style ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est pas les pharmaciens qui ont
demandé de ne pas livrer les médecins je
pense que c'est là la pénurie qui fait
qu'il ya très peu de vaccins disponibles
et qui fait que le gouvernement la dgs a
décidé peut-être de priver des
pharmaciens cette fois ci un peu pour
compter un peu les troupes voir combien
de pharmaciens elle en commandé à
combien de temps allait envoyer un
flacon de 10 pour ensuite la semaine
suivante on va mais on aura les choses à
plat et un rebond reverra et on aura une
redistribution qui sera je pense plus
équitable je suis d'accord que docteur
marty on est là pour travailler ensemble
ont cette fois ci ça a été géré un peu
on était au cir surpris moi quand j'ai
lu de le dgs je pense à peu près la même
heure puisqu'on est dans sa tombe en
même temps j'étais assez surpris de 7,7
ce choix de ne pas nous laisser comment
de m alors comment tu pas nos grossistes
parce qu'avec nos grossistes ont sa
colère on recommande à la rsc des restes
qui transmet à nos grossistes donc ce
qui fait qu effectivement ce matin le
camp d'essayer de hong kong se
connectent on n'a pas à l'accès à la
commande pour les médecins on peut même
pas le faire quoi c'est cette décision
qui a été prise par le gouvernement
voilà on est bloqué mais je pense qu'une
pause notion de pénurie on en gère une
pénurie a pas il y en a pas assez donc
cette fois ci on en aura un peu pour la
semaine prochaine
on ne rend les recevoir le 19 un la
semaine du cadre et sera quand même des
d'entamer puisque ce sera le vendredi
tant qu'ils imaginent qu'on commencera
vacciner que le lundi pour avoir 30
quads sûr de pouvoir bien faire nos dix
doses par jérôme marty vous nous dites
si je vois là si je me trompe mais c'est
vrai qu'on a du mal à suivre en fait
cette logistique ça veut dire ans
en clair à tous vous entendre qu'on aura
quoi une une semaine de vaccination plus
ou moins blanches entre les pharmacies
les médecins parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
médecins qui sont obligés d'annuler leur
rendez-vous les pharmaciens ne seront
pas prêts avant la semaine prochaine ça
veut dire trois compères une semaine
dans cette affaire surtout ça veut dire
que monsieur salomon et à une doctrine
c'est la percée dans la confusion
personne n'y comprend plus rien on nous
annonce que pour la semaine 8 1 dispose
de très peu de doses et que c'est pour
ça qu'on ne peut fournir que les
officines et ne peuvent commander que
pour elle même on nous parle de 28 mille
doses dans le même temps le communiqué
en quelque sorte de correction peloux
fait la dgs cet après midi vers 17
heures nous parle de 560 mille doses
entre le 11 et le 12 mars pour les
médecins donc pénurie où la pénurie
faire on est dans une espèce de
l'opacité totale
je vous rappelle que depuis le début le
tout début de la campagne vaccinale
on demande à ce qu'une autorité
indépendante visant permanence l'état
des stocks
c'est à dire que il nous intéresse peu
de savoir combien on donne deux fleuves
pour aux pharmaciens et aux médecins etc
ça ça nous intéresse pas parce que si la
vol ce qui vous intéresse et damman de
combien dispose at on réellement de
stock et qu'on arrête de nous balader on
est en train de vivre ni plus ni moins
la même chose que ce qui s'est passé au
moins de la crise des masses avait
pardonné moins chère martine mon cou
parce qu'il ya eu des chiffres assez
précis là des gestes qui nous a répondu
à aux médecins en vous disant voilà ce
sont plus de 1 million un million six
pardon revient que j'ai des problèmes
avec les chiffres ce soit 1,6 million de
doses du vaccin d'astrazeneca qui ont
été livrées aux médecins sous-entendu
voilà c'est suffisant mais madame vous
dit exactement la même chose que moi
c'est à dire qu'ils nous disent qu'il
est livré aux médecins moi ça ça
m'intéresse pas ce qui m'intéresse série
stocks
c'est l'état des stocks qu'est ce qui va
être livrée ça ça m'intéresse
ce qui a été livrée ça ne m'intéresse
pas moi ce qui m'intéresse et ceux qui
souhaitent cloche
ce que l'on ne cache pas ce que l'on
voit ça ça m'intéresse parce que ça ça
me permet de me projeter sur les jours
qui viennent alors que depuis le début
nous sommes dans l'incapacité de nous
projeter dans les jours qui viennent
et ça ça suffit ouais c'est ce qu'on a
vécu pendant les mêmes choses je
voudrais vous montrer quelques chiffres
on y verra peut-être plus clair sur les
doses
regardez astrazeneca plus d'un million
cent mille doses à 24 0 3% feather
biotech plus de 4 millions de doses qui
ont été livrés modern à 72 81 % alors
évidemment 24 0 3% plus de un million
cent mille doses seul 273 me
l'administré c'est pas beaucoup pour
quelle raison n'a utilisé que ces doses
où sont les vaccins d'astrazeneca
si je peux me permettre les vaccins
d'astrazeneca
on les a commandées pour les médecins on
a envoyé deux doses supplémentaires
comme monnaie de réserve et dans
certains cas donc tous les pharmaciens
ne les ont pas délivré ces deux doses
supplémentaires et surtout la campagne
dans la peau de chance elle a démarré en
plein pendant les vacances scolaires
donc beaucoup de médecins étaient soit
absent soit ils avaient peur trop trop
de patients sont absents ce qui fait que
ce million de doses là il est bien
arrivé dans les officines il n'a pas
toujours été pris par les médecins ou
qu'elles étaient près par le médecin la
pâture été injectés parce que c'était un
peu compliqué de réunir les dix patients
qu'il fallait dans les six heures si les
potes frigo ou dans les 2 jours s'ils
veulent frigo et je pense que c'est ce
phénomène là qui est peut-être inciter
aussi le les autorités à dire bon on va
voir ce qu'on va vraiment donner aux
pharmaciens puisque les médecins
apparemment ils ont encore sept cent
mille soultz 700 villes qui sont soit
l'officine soit chez les médecins et
qu'il va falloir injecter je pense que
c'est ça en plus on attend c'est ce que
disait dr marty on attend pour la fin de
semaine
580 mille cinq cent soixante mille doses
supplémentaires qui vont arriver la
zoophilie à destination des médecins ses
lauriers aussi en slovaquie lie à un
quinze mille doses qui sont partis en
slovaquie et basse et on peut apprécier
ou pas reprenez quand je dis il faut
qu'on sache l'état des stocks c'est
parce que quand on fait des opérations
coup de poing comme ce qui s'est passé
ce week end où je rappelle quand même
que libé scène pendant les autres
soignants nous avons
globalement 12 heures on veut retourner
puisque nous avons appris le vendredi
matin pour lancer l'opération de
vaccination le samedi le dimanche 12
heures pour nous retourner quand on gère
c'est que c'est quoi ces opérations là
on mange du vaccin on les prend soin des
stocks
ces vaccins on les sort pas de nulle
part ils ont été puis deux boules cela
ils vont me bats pour être utilisée
ensuite pour distribuer soit dans les
officines soit aux mecs elle donc bien
de quelque part c'est pour ça qu'on a
besoin de connaître l'état des stocks
encore une fois je vous rappelle que ce
qui a présidé les deux mots qui ont
présidé à la mise en place de la
campagne vaccinale du président de la
république n ça a été transparence et
confiance
actuellement on n'a ni transparence ni
confiance jérôme marty vous mettez ça
sur quel compte d'un manque
d'organisation à manque comme vous dites
de transparents met sciemment qu'est-ce
qui tourne mal parce que c'est vrai
quand on a du mal à comprendre cette
campagne de vaccination n'a pas beaucoup
de vacances les disputes entre
pharmaciens et médecins il ya des
vaccinodromes mais ya pas de ne rien
comprendre vu de l'extérieur en tout cas
c'est très facile à expliquer ce
gouvernement mais comme d'autres
précédemment a totalement oublié qu'il
existait une médecine libérale et quand
je dis mais s'ils entendent pharmaciens
infirmières ce qui fait le monde libéral
ils ont oublié que ça existait et donc
ils prennent des décisions sans la
présence de nos représentants fait les
pharmaciens des syndicats les médecins
indiquent syndicats les infirmières ont
des syndicats
il serait quand même assez facile que
l'on mette au moins autour de l'automne
et vos représentants du mode de libéral
quand on lance une campagne vaccinale
aussi importante que celle que l'on est
en train de lancer par rapport à une
bière et comme le pouce contre la
corrida même la moindre des choses
serait que nos représentants participent
aux décisions ne serait ce que pour dire
au directeur général de la santé
attention ça c'est possible ça c'est pas
possible là où facebook route
là on va vous aider et c'est non non
nous sort déçu parce que nos députés
fait et puis après que pour après demain
on va lancer dedans participation
nationale le week-end ça suffit - denis
millet le mot de la fin pour vous avec
la fin pour vous avec les objectifs
ambitieux annoncé par le gouvernement
qui veut augmenter sa cadence vous
et croyez à ces chiffres promis par le
gouvernement vous restait néanmoins
optimiste sur cette campagne vaccinale
je reste optimiste parce que on voit
ensemble des libéraux sont sont
mobilisés on va arriver à vacciner on va
arriver avec à faire les doses qu'on va
nous qu'on voudra bien nous donner
maintenant on nous promet vous aviez
ouvert le journal avec les promesses de
dany espagne est relâchée sur 4 millions
d'astrazeneca 1 millions par semaine
tant mieux si ce million arrive on
pourra se partagent équitablement rideau
cromartie on aura chacun notre ration et
on pourra vacciner un maximum de
patients parce que les patients
attendent toutes les formations ouvert
déjà des listes énorme moi je dois être
plus de 50 femmes patients qui m'ont
demandé après il y aura des échanges et
des endroits où les pharmaciens veulent
pas vaccinés notre angoisse et de 25 kg
pas vacciner donc c'est bien que tout le
monde soit prêt et on y arrivera on
arrivera à faire les deux qu'on nous
donnera mais ça le millions par semaine
selon ccc le mot de la fin effectivement
gros point d'interrogation sur le long
des doses ce soir c'est ce qu'on
retiendra mercier tous les deux j'ai
remarqué denis millet d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur rt france ouverture
aujourd'hui à paris du procès en appel
de la banque privée suisse ubs
l'établissement bancaire condamné en
première instance en février 2019 à une
amende de 3 milliards 700 millions
d'euros dans une affaire d'évasion
fiscale on retrouve tout de suite katia
technique en direct de la cour d'appel
de paris
bonsoir katia un procès très attendu
qu'elle et son enjeu
et oui vous vous souvenez de ce cet
énorme scandale financier alors la
banque ubs a été condamné en février
2019 à la plus lourde amende en matière
d'évasion fiscale 4,5 milliards d'euros
elle est accusée d'avoir entre 2004 et
démarcher des clients français sur le
territoire national mais avec des
chargés d'affaires suisses et c'est
totalement illégal autres chefs
d'accusation le blanchiment aggravé de
fraude fiscale pour les clients français
38 mille comptes avaient été découverts
par les enquêteurs qui représentait plus
de 12 milliards qui ont échappé au fisc
au fisc français bien sûr mais que s'est
il passé à katia au cours de cette
première journée d'audience hommes
alors il ya évidemment des ténors du
barreau à la barre comme hervé temime
qui était présent au procès de nicolas
sarkozy alors par exemple un des avocats
a demandé la nullité de la procédure en
expliquant qu'il n'y avait pas de
précisions sur les fameux démarchage
dont je vous parlais tout à l'heure
combien quel client à quelle date est en
fait tous s'appliquent à décrédibiliser
elle était moins parce que les
informations fuitées ont été donnés par
des lanceurs d'alert ancien
collaborateur du bs donc il ya des
lacunes d'information bien sûr
alors comment les avocats vont essayer
de faire écarter toutes les pièces et
bien par exemple en invoquant le secret
bancaire qui avait cours à l'époque en
suisse et les avocats ont aussi éreinté
nathalie gibeau la fameuse lanceuse d'
alerte qui a été interviewé par rt
france ils ont dit qu'elles avaient été
qui elle avait été déclarée
collaboratrice occasionnels du service
public parce qu'elle a collaboré avec
les douanes 1 pour raconter les secrets
du bs et que donc le service public
avait obtenu des preuves de manière
illicite
maître denis chemla un autre ténor du
barreau a demandé qu'on écarte des
pièces qui ont été obtenues du côté de
l'allemagne hors du cadre régissant
l'entrée de juridica vous voyez
discrédit des preuves discrédit des
témoins demande de nullité de la
procédure les avocats font tout leur
possible pour tenter de sauver ubs a
dans cette gigantesque histoire affaire
d'évasion fiscale présumée merci katia
technique
dans l'actualité également en france à
champigny sur marne dans le val de marne
on a appris ce soir qu'une violente rixe
entre bandes rivales avaient éclaté en
fin de journée deux adolescents de 14 et
15 ans ont été blessés à l'armé blanche
le plus jeune très grièvement cinq
suspects ont été interpellés et il n'a
qu'à demi ces dernières heures dans
l'agglomération lyonnaise après à trois
soirées de violences consécutives un
regain de tension entre des groupes de
jeunes et les forces de l'ordre après un
accident de scooter une enquête est en
cours
les autorités restent inquiètes ils ont
envoyé des renforts hélène masquelier
bron samedi soir une équipe de police
est prise à partie poubelles et voitures
incendiés tirs de mortier et feu
d'artifice une troisième nuit de
violences pour la métropole lyonnaise
bilan cinq interpellations le préfet
délégué pour la défense et la sécurité
dénonce des jeunes venus casser du flic
tous les soirs en ce moment
au delà des incendies de voitures
l'objectif c'est prendre à partie les
policiers
éventuellement les pompiers donc là
aussi on s'attend à être caillassé ce
soir il ya plusieurs petits groupes
d'individus qui ont tenté de s'en
prendre à la police
une nouvelle fois la présence des forces
de l'ordre a permis de limiter ces
exactions ne laisse pas rien passé on
n'accepte pas les actes de violence
on n'accepte pas ce climat malsain et
nous serons présents pour tenter
d'empêcher la veille c'est la commune de
rillieux la pape qui avait été le
théâtre de violences des actes de
vandalisme perpétrés par un peu plus
d'une trentaine de jeunes
six personnes sont interpellées tandis
que le maire de rillieux la pape est la
cible de menaces de mort j'ai été de
nouveau menacé de décapitation
bien entendu je porterai plainte pour
ces faits intolérables
je ne baisserai jamais les yeux face à
ces délinquants dont la place n'est plus
dans nos rues
mais en prison à l'origine de ces
affrontements un incident de scooter
mercredi qui met le feu aux poudres dans
le quartier lyonnais de la duchère un
adolescent de 13 ans qui roulait sans
casque est gravement blessé selon des
jeunes du quartier il était poursuivi
par une voiture de police banalisée en
représailles un groupe de jeunes s'en
est pris aux forces de l'ordre
enclenchant cette série de
confrontations avec la police selon le
ministre de l'intérieur les opérations
policières anti drogue visant à
démanteler les trafics de la métropole
serait à l'origine de ces tensions
s'il ya des violences urbaines s'il ya
des voitures qui peuvent brûler des
policiers qui sont pris à partie des
élus menacée c'est parce qu'avec les
polices municipales mais avec la police
nationale en premier lieu on intervient
on démantèle chaque jour des points de
deal
plus il y aura harcèlement de ses points
de deal plus il ya manifestement
réaction des dealers mais à la fin ce
sera toujours la police qui va gagner
pour l'heure gérald darmanin a annoncé
un bilan total de 21 une interpellation
dans l'agglomération lyonnaise dont une
majorité de mineurs le ministre de
l'intérieur qui a annoncé l'envoi de 200
policiers en renfort dans la zone
pour prévenir une escalade des violences
est resté avec nous dans quelques
instants nous parlerons du procès de
derek chauvine policiers accusés d'avoir
tué john floyd le 25 mai dernier un
procès qui devait s'ouvrir aujourd'hui à
minneapolis finalement reporté et puis
direction la birmanie où de multiples
rassemblements dans tout pays appellent
à la grève générale ont éclaté les
principaux syndicats veulent
l'intensifier pour étouffer l'économie
et faire pression sur la junte
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes né dans la musique vous êtes
né dans une famille d'artistes désir
révélée brutalement par la prise de
conscience du concert symphonique qui
m'a donné envie d'être chef d'orchestre
ça a balayé tout le reste c'est un acte
d'amour la musique pour vous oui mais
l'art en général vous savez ça permet de
mieux se connaître ça permet de mieux
partager c'est la part d'humanité
incontournable et indispensable à
l'évolution de tout être humain quand
vous entendez pata pata pata pata pata
pata pata pata pata pata papa parents
pata pata
vous avez envie de faire ça il faut que
leur qu'istres groove la musique c'est
la traduction la plus poétique de la vie
si vous mettez pas la vie des vides à
mon sens bête
il faut sortir les notes de leurs
univers carcéral
mais il faut jouer ce qui a entre les
notes et avant tout c'est le rythme et
la pulsation et ça c'est fondamental
pour entraîner et l' enthousiasme des
musiciens et celui du public
[Musique]
freiner le réchauffement climatique tout
en stimulant la croissance voici a
grossièrement la finalité de ce que l'on
appelle communément la relance verte
qu'est ce que vous voulez faire comme
relance verte quand vous avez une
économie qui est entièrement mondialisée
c'est des mots c'est de la com
chez non seulement indispensable mais
c'est une condition de survie à moyen
long terme de l'espèce humaine
le premier grand sujet c'est de réduire
l'usagé du pétrole et du gaz dans nos
gestes quotidiens
oui il faudrait faire quelque chose mais
on ne s'en donne absolument pas les
moyens et on n'a pas du tout envie même
bill gates de dire son dernier bouquin
aucune trajectoire n'est possible si on
réduit pas notre consommation d'énergie
monsieur le maire nous explique qu'on va
rembourser toutes leurs bêtises avec une
croissance exceptionnellement forte je
voudrais qu'on m'explique comment on va
arriver à baisser la consommation
d'énergie et faire 6% de croissance de
l'autre côté ça va être compliqué
[Musique]
il ya à peu près un enfant sur deux en
france qui est soit victime soit hauteur
de cyber violence sur internet un
contenu haineux de quelqu'un qui dit à
une fillette de 8 ans on va te suicider
ça ça doit être retirée immédiatement il
n'ya aucun débat à avoir sur son retrait
là parce que ça ça fait des suicides la
loi le condamne déjà c'est déjà interdit
de faire ça bien sûr mais c'est juste
que le légat fans ne l'appliquent pas la
justice est lente et c'est très
problématique qui doit prendre ce rôle
de régulateur la loi peut aider
l'éducation peut aider selon les
différentes catégories d'attaquants et
d'attaquer une erreur de la loi via ça a
été de tout mettre dans le même panier
sous le sous le nom et no line quel rôle
pour les réseaux sociaux on a vu et big
for donc les cafards s'organiser pour
annuler quelqu'un sur internet ce que
quelqu'un s'était donald trump quand il
s'agit d'un bannissement si général pour
moi ce n'est pas aux gaffes à et aux
réseaux sociaux à dont l'un des
entreprises privées de prendre cette
décision mais ça doit être à la justice
de prendre cette décision
[Musique]
avec les accords d'abraham le président
américain reconnaît la souveraineté du
maroc sur le sahara fuyant la france
comme l'europe a été absente de
l'ensemble de cette négociation qui
impactent directement deux pays dans
lesquels nous avons des liens
privilégiés depuis fort longtemps la
république algérienne et le royaume du
maroc des algériens évidemment
mécontents considère la décision
américaine comme une ingérence dans un
problème interne
le maroc a toujours été considérée comme
une menace politique économique et
militaire
face à cette situation conflictuelle
entre les deux pays la france aurait
ainsi l'occasion de participer à la
construction d'un maghreb pacifiées
[Musique]
chaque jour en politique des milliers de
parties d'échecs sont joués mais les
règles ne sont pas toujours respectées
les couleurs changent de camp les pions
prennent la place des rois de fine
stratégie peuvent porter des résultats
inattendus
un coup décisif ne fait que repousser la
victoire
monsieur les chômeurs et chaque semaine
dans l'échiquier mondial nous
analyserons les coups les plus complexes
du jeu politique internationale
[Musique]
à bientôt sur rd france un bonsoir à
tous merci de nous rejoindre en direct
sur rt france 20h30 heure de paris aux
états unis le procès de derek chauvine
policiers accusés d'avoir tué de georges
de freerolls et reportée par décision du
juge il devait s'ouvrir ce matin
minneapolis mais ne devrait pas débuter
avant demain au moins l'émotion est
toujours vive dans le pays elle est
aujourd'hui des milliers de manifestants
ont défilé dans les rues robin pu elle
avec pierre pissavy yvernault c'est un
procès hors normes qui devait s'ouvrir
aujourd'hui celui de derek chauvine
policier accusé d'avoir étouffé d'orge
floyd le 25 mai dernier
remise en liberté sous caution cet homme
de 44 ans est présenté comme prévu
devant la justice à minneapolis ce lundi
matin mais par décision du juge
le procès est reporté loin de
l'attention de minneapolis la famille de
georges klein se prépare à plusieurs
semaines éprouvantes mais entend rester
optimiste on a parlé du procès on a prié
pour ça on va garder la foi on est
optimiste sur ce qui va se passer parce
qu'on a une bonne équipe derrière nous
on pense qu'on va obtenir une
condamnation et qu'on va obtenir justice
la famille de georges floyd sait que ça
va être une longue épreuve
elle envisage que ça puisse durer de
quatre à huit semaines alors cette
famille et c'est juste comme elle le dit
de se préparer au mieux à cette épreuve
et à ce procès marathon
aux etats unis la mort de georges floyd
lors d'une banale interpellation avait
mis en lumière les fractures entre
forces de l'ordre et minorités raciales
d'importantes manifestations avaient
secoué les grandes villes du pays et
soulevé une vague mondiale d'indignation
dans le minnesota la mobilisation pour
la justice et pour démontrer la
responsabilité des policiers ne s'est
jamais arrêté et depuis ce week end
de nouveaux rassemblements se sont
multipliées les policiers traitent toute
la ville comme si nous étions des
détenus aient eu des agents de
correction
nous n'avons pas besoin d'être corrigés
nous vous surveillons et nous en avons
fini de la surveillance j'espère que
derek chauvine sera condamné pour
homicide car ce qu'il a fait était mal
nous avons vu tout ce qu'il a fait et
j'espère qu'ils ne diront pas que d'orge
floyd est mort d'une overdose
alors que le monde entier a vu des
règles chauvine agenouillé sur son cou
le procès débutera par la sélection du
jury un moment qui s'avère déjà délicat
pour les différentes parties de longues
discussions sont attendus et ce dès les
premières heures du procès afin de
trouver les personnes les plus neutre
possible le début des audiences est
quant à lui prévu pour le 29 mars
prochain et pour en parler nous sommes
en direct depuis washington avec tristan
cabello maître de conférences en
civilisation américaine à l'université
johns hopkins spécialiste de l'histoire
afro-américaine c'est notre rubrique
vieux de l'extérieur ce soir
[Musique]
bonsoir christan kabylo merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france qu'on
s'est donc reportée en par décision du
juge pourtant tout avait l'air a priori
d'être prêts notamment au niveau de la
sécurité parce que c'est important dans
ce type de procès pourquoi ce retard
selon vous il semblerait que les avocats
de derek chemin est fait appel j'ai eu
des coups de culpabilité
ce qui est tout à fait normal et ce
qu'ils avaient tout à fait le droit de
faire ça va être juste un petit retard
là peut-être de 24 heures et la
sélection du mans commencé t2 après ça
on va s'attendre très certainement à
quatre semaines de sélection a process
de sélection du jury et le procès en
lui-même ne devrait pas commencer avant
le 29 mars
alors justement la sélection des jurés à
castets on imagine dans ce type de
procès très médiatisé très politisé même
tout à fait lorsqu'il faut savoir aux
etats unis c'est que tous les citoyens
américains majeurs peuvent être appelés
à la cour pour être membre de jury dans
toutes les affaires pénales et donc pour
cette affaire précise le cas de georges
claude qu'il soit tout à fait impartial
et ça va être très difficile car c'est
quand même une affaire de ton qu'on
avait tous les détails se dérouler sous
nos yeux et ont tout le monde est au
courant donc depuis quelques semaines
l'état
2 du minnesota on voit des
questionnaires à des potentiels jurés
donc ces questionnaires font à peu près
16 à 17 pages on leur demande absolument
toute leur vie est ce qu'ils ont été
impactés par des émeutes connaissait-il
georges claude et sa famille quel genre
de média quel genre de podcasts quel
genre de livre ils lisent pour afin de
d'essayer de déterminer finalement leur
position sur sur le spectre politique
comment être neutre justement devant ce
type de procès comment justement ne pas
faire un procès avant l'heure en sachant
tous deux de ses jurés alors c'est tout
à fait impossible y tout à fait
impossible d'être complètement impartial
dans ce procès car c'est un procès qui
était tout à fait médiatique et qu'on a
vu se dérouler sous nos yeux
quand on a vu les éléments du procès se
déroule sous nos yeux durant dès les
derniers mois par contre ce que le lait
jus nez et les sélectionneurs du jury
vont de reconnaître ici ça n'est pas ça
n'est pas de sélectionner des gens qui
vont être impartiaux mais des gens qui
vont pouvoir décider en dépit de leurs
billets d'avoir un jugement impartial
donc ils savent très bien le
sélectionneur ça va tenues manque
personne ne va être complètement
impartial
durant ce jeu se ce procès mais il faut
que les gens aient conscience de leurs
billets alors derek sherwin en tout cas
lui et risque la prison à perpétuité
son procès en plein mouvement black live
matters pourrait-il on imagine servir
d'exemple il est compliqué de rendre
justice
sereinement encore une fois dans ce type
d'affaires très très politique parce que
tout le monde l'attend ce procès aux
états unis avec des émeutes que
évidemment cela a provoqué oui parce que
c'est en fait un procès qui est tout à
fait historique et s'impose acquis
historique pour trois raisons d'abord il
ya la figure de georges claude tout à
fait symbolique on a vu et on le voit
sur vos écrans ce moment c'est quelqu'un
qui a vraiment été une cause rallye
tain de tous de tous les cris pour
toutes les les rassemblements pour
contrôler les violences policières
partout dans le monde
c'est aussi le premier procès le premier
procès pour violences policières de
l'herbe hayden et on sait bien que au
centre de son homme le combat pour la
justice et pour l'égalité raciale
et puis enfin et je pense c'est ce qu'il
ya de plus important ici c'est que c'est
que le premier procès post 6 janvier le
6 janvier on a vu des militants pour la
plupart blanc qui ont pu comme ça
prendre le capitole sans que sans qu'ils
ne soient inquiétés par la police
et de l'autre côté on a ce georgia floyd
dont on ne sait pas très bien de quoi il
était coupable qui a été qui a été tué
par un policier et donc là comme vous
l'avez dit très bien
c'est vraiment un pays qui est à bout de
souffle qui est vraiment divisé et on
peut s'attendre durant ce procès
vraiment à de nombreuses manifestations
et quelle que soit l'issue même du
procès certainement à des émeutes
oui c'était ma prochaine question il va
falloir faire très attention à l'issue
de ce procès aux peines prononcées au
risque de provoquer ces nouvelles
émeutes
il va vouloir apaiser ça va être très
difficile pour les juges
oui c'est très difficile pour les juste
à être très difficile pour pour le
président biden et ollon voilà que même
avant que le procès ne démarre il y à
déjà en fait des manifestations des
protestations il va sans dire il est
absolument que s'il ya un lieu si derek
sherwin n'est pas jugée coupable qu'il y
aura des émeutes d'une ampleur peut être
catastrophique dans le pays puisque on
sait déjà ce sont ces la mort de georges
claude qui a généré ces émeutes de au
mois de mai on peut attendre à une issue
du procès qu'ils aient lieu en plus
juste un an après la mort de georges lot
donc la date anniversaire
ce qui ferait qu'amplifier un non lieu
ou une non culpabilité de derek sherwin
savait parler effectivement de joe biden
qui entrent en piste la police on le
rappelle a toujours été défendu
farouchement par donald trump le fait
que ce procès s'ouvre sous l'herbe
hayden est ce que ça peut changer
quelque chose
by dell n'avait pas vraiment un discours
tout à fait différent de donald trump
est on se rappelle des méthodes de
kenosha durant la campagne ou lui aussi
appelé à l'eau à une rue de la loi et
l'ordre tout comme trump l'avait faible
par contre là c'est j'ai envie de dire
le premier test de l'administration m'a
étonné c'est un test vraiment important
ce comme je le rappelais précédemment
joe biden a mis la justice raciale et la
justice sociale au centre de cette
plateforme
et s'il ya un non lieu ou une
culpabilité de derrick chauvine ça sera
vraiment un coup assez sec durant les
premières semaines de son administration
merci à tristan cabello maître de
conférences en civilisation américaine à
l'université johns hopkins
nouvelle la mobilisation au liban contre
la chute de la livre libanaise et les
conditions de vie de plus en plus
difficile dans ce pays qui fait face à
une grave crise économique
aujourd'hui des manifestants se sont
réunis pour bloquer les axes routiers
menant à la capitale barricades ne en
feu les contestataires ont barré une
bonne partie des axes menant à beyrouth
ça fait maintenant une semaine que les
manifestations ont repris au liban la
classe politique accusée d'avoir mené le
pays à la faillite est également dans le
collimateur des manifestants
écouter certains entre le dollar vaut
désormais dix mille livres libanaises je
ne peux pas trouver de l'aide pour mon
fils ma voiture ne marche plus et je ne
peux pas la réparer bon salaire vaut
désormais 150 $ qu'est ce que je peux
dire de plus je ne peut plus nourrir ma
famille à la fin du mois aujourd'hui un
dollar vaut entre 10000 et 12000 livres
libanaises nous ne pouvons rien donner à
nos enfants nos enfants à l'étranger
souffre ils les empêchent de s'inscrire
aux cours universitaires nous avons
essayé des larmes et tout le monde à ce
sujet vingt trois militants anti gens
tués aujourd'hui en birmanie dans de
nouvelles protestations contre l'armée
au pouvoir
la mobilisation contre ce coup d'état
militaire du 1er février ayant abouti à
l'assignation à résidence de l'ex chef
du gouvernement à 100 succi elle ne
faiblit pas de nombreuses banques
commerciales industrielles restées
fermées aujourd'hui après l'appel des
syndicats à intensifier la grève les
minorités ethniques ont rejoint la
contestation selon l'onu près de 200
manifestants sont encerclés par des
forces de sécurité à paris des dizaines
de personnes ont manifesté près de
l'ambassade birmane ils réclament l'aide
de la communauté internationale
[Musique]
aujourd'hui on 21e siècle on ne peut pas
fermer les yeux face à face là on est
nous sommes civilisés oyonnax nous avons
2021 donc à jeux de mots les communauté
internationale les mots ne suffisaient
plus nous avons posé en tête il ya plus
de soixante fait qu son nom en birmanie
là c'est tout ça nous on l'a ici ouvert
un hommage où les héros notre héros en
birmanie pour la démocratie en birmanie
où la liberté en birmanie pour en parler
nous sommes à technaute blanchemaison
expert en relations internationales
bonsoir co2 blanchemaison merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france les
militaires birmans qui maîtrisent la
situation ou non dans le pays
quel est justement la situation en bon
militaire il avait parfaitement planifié
leur coup d'état
dès que les élections du 20 novembre au
produit les résultats que il ne pouvait
pas accepter puisque cette majorité très
importante pour le parti de madame suu
kyi risque et lorsque l'assemblée se
réuniraient de conduire à une révision
de la constitution que les militaires
avaient écrites en 2008 et c'est cette
constitution qui prévoit pour eux des
sièges au parlement
vingt-cinq pour cent qui prévoient pour
eux que le ministère de la défense
ministère de l'intérieur et le mystère
des frontières leur est réservé et non
pas à répondre aux chefs de gouvernement
sur ces sujets là et se gèrent eux mêmes
et aussi le fait qu' ils ont un rôle
très important en matière économique et
que le parti de madame aung san suu kyi
était bien déterminé à limiter ce rôle
et surtout à lutter contre la corruption
donc ils ont planifié le coup d'état
pour le 1er février puisque c'était le
jour où devaient se réunir ce nouveau
parlement
mais ils ont fait une grave erreur ils
ont sous-estimé
grandement la la capacité de lutte de la
société civile d'hermann probablement
qu'ils étaient mal informés probablement
ils ont sous-estimé le caractère
inacceptable d'un nouveau coup d'état en
birmanie pour la jeunesse est en effet
depuis le 1er février
et bien la population birmane est dans
la rue et manifestent contre ce coup
l'état maintenant il ya une grève
générale et par conséquent le pays est à
l'arrêt on voit également que dans les
services publics mais bien beaucoup de
fonctionnaires ne travaille plus
certains policiers aujourd'hui ont
traversé la frontière en direction de
l'inde
et ça effectivement c'est un c'est ainsi
ça veut dire que les choses sont en
train de bouger et que peut-être que les
militaires sont en train de perdre la
main mais bien entendu le pays pendant
ce temps-là s'enfonce dans la crise et
malheureusement peut-être vers de
nombreux morts alors les femmes mais
aussi les jeunes quelle place tiennent
t-il au sein de ce mouvement de
contestation
mercredi le mercredi noir aux régions où
il ya eu 38 morts parmi ces 38 morts il
ya eu un vandale est une jeune femme qui
avait 19 ans qui marchait en tête d'un
défilé naturellement pacifiquement
puisque tous les défilés sont pacifiques
il n'y a pas de casseurs dans ces
manifestations
et elle a été tué d'une balle dans la
tête là les militaires ont voulu faire
d'une expertise et faire croire qu'elles
avaient été tués par des manifestants
puisque la balle est entrée par
l'arrière de sa tête en réalité c'est
parce quand elle s'enfuyait lorsque les
militaires ont commencé à charger et
aujourd'hui elle est un peu l'icône de
l'icône delà de la lutte de la lutte
pour la liberté contre la junte
militaire
et puis tous ces jeunes évidemment son
son temps jean en basket et le chef de
la junte a cru utile de
dire que que ces jeunes ne serait ce que
par leur attitude leur habillement ne
respecte ne respectez pas à l'autorité
des militaires et ne respectez pas les
traditions birman en effet il ya un
décalage dans le temps une sorte
d'anachronisme birman les militaires ne
connaissent plus la société birmane
d'aujourd'hui alors que peut faire dans
ce contexte la communauté internationale
face à ce bras de fer en birmanie il n'y
a pas vraiment de communauté
internationale ou s'il y en a eu une
année pluriel puisque depuis plusieurs
jours on n'arrive pas à se mettre
d'accord au conseil de sécurité des
nations-unies sur le texte d'une
déclaration d'une simple déclaration il
s'agit même pas d'une résolution pour
l'action mais la chine met son veto à
tout texte parce qu' elle ne veut
surtout pas ouvrir la porte à une
éventuelle intervention extérieure
quelle qu'elle soit que ce soit à l'onu
où que ce soit tout sous toute autre
forme
et puis en même temps elle appelle au
dialogue parce que elle défend ses
intérêts qui sont importants en birmanie
et notamment ses investissements dans ce
qu'on appelle le corridor nord-sud qui
relie en fait directement la chine à
l'océan indien pour les autres pays et
bien les états unis de monsieur biden
ont sanctionné neuf généraux qui font
partie de la junte
c'est à dire que leurs avoirs sont gelés
la grande-bretagne en a sanctionné trois
de la même manière qui s'ajoutent à ceux
que de que l'union européenne avait
sanctionné
lorsque l'héroïne gars avaient été
chassés de leur territoire
et puis l'union européenne s'apprête à
prendre des mesures complémentaires
d'une part sanctions contre certains
chefs militaires et d'autre part
peut-être d'ici à fin du mois c'est les
ministres des affaires étrangères qui
devront décider interdiction de traiter
avec les entités économiques qui
dépendent directement des militaires ou
de leurs familles et là effectivement ça
risque de faire un peu plus mal aux
personnes concernées
parce que le gel de leurs avoirs à
l'étranger c'est un peu symbolique ils
en ont ils n'ont pas tous cas dans les
pays occidentaux
peut-être en entier dans l'asie mais ils
en ont pas dans les pays occidentaux en
revanche l'interdiction de faire des
affaires avec des groupes des
consortiums qui le prennent loin
appartiennent aux familles des
militaires
ça risque de les frapper davantage alors
dans tout ça il ya quand même les
voisins autre que la chine et dans les
voisins autre que la chine il y à l'inde
il y a les pays d'asie du sud est asean
dont la birmanie fait partie
et puis il ya un autre groupement qui
comporte la birmanie et la thaïlande
deux pays aujourd'hui très peu
démocratique mais aussi tous les pays
d'asie du sud c'est à dire l'un d'eux
scellant le bangladesh le bhoutan le
népal et c'est peut-être du côté de la
zad et du beauté de ce deuxième
groupement dont le sigle un peu bizarre
s'appelle bim steak c'est peut-être de
ce côté là que certains pays pourraient
jouer un rôle pour essayer de restaurer
un dialogue qui permettrait en effet
d'éviter l'effusion de sang
mais en réalité les possibilités de ce
dialogue se sont bien fait puisque les
militaires sont tout à fait déterminé à
écraser la contestation a écrasé la
l'opposition à leur coup d'état
merci claude blanche maison pour votre
analyse m
et dans le reste de l'actualité la
suisse qui adopte l'interdiction de se
couvrir le visage dans l'espace public à
une courte majorité un référendum sur
cette initiative avait lieu hier sur un
sujet qui divise le pays
cette derrière cette interdiction c'est
en réalité le voile intégral porté par
les femmes de confession musulmane qui
visait mathilde romagnan lutte contre
l'islam radical ou dérives xénophobes
le texte sur l'interdiction de se
dissimuler le visage en public a été
acceptée hier par les électeurs suisses
à 51,21 % des voix l'initiative portée
par le parti populiste udc n'évoque ni
la burqa ni le niqab mais vise
directement les femmes musulmanes
portant le voile intégral
le résultat est à l'image de la division
des partis politiques suisses sur le
sujet les partisans du texte salue un
signal fort contre l'islam radical
ses opposants dénoncent une initiative
sexistes et xénophobe être libre c'est
pouvoir montrer son visage respecter la
dignité de la femme à avoir une identité
et donc je ne comprends pas
l'argumentation des personnes qui
veulent emprisonner des femmes derrière
ce voile on a voté pour un texte qui
concerne une trentaine de femmes donc
c'est vraiment un usage démagogique
d'une initiative que ce droit
d'initiative populaire
et c'est dans ce sens là que l'on le
dénonce vraiment cet usage démagogique
et puis cette volonté de str attiser une
communauté qui est extrêmement bien
intégrés chez nous en suisse
et si la classe politique est partagé la
population suisse l'est tout autant et
d'autre et les dc
un décès je ne pense pas que ça va
vraiment comment dire que ça va vraiment
dissipé la menace terroriste mais c'est
surtout quelque chose de symbolique à
long terme est ce que ce sera une bonne
chose ou non je ne peux pas le dire car
c'est ma liberté je ne voudrais pas que
quelqu'un me force à enlever mon voile
ou à lemaitre d'une certaine manière
finalement ce n'est pas très différente
de porter un masque ou pas je pense que
chacun devrait décider chacun doit
pouvoir choisir s'il couvre son visage
ou non ça ne devrait pas être contrôlée
par la loi en 2009 les suisses avaient
déjà voté l'interdiction de la
construction de minarets sur les
mosquées selon les chiffres de l'office
des statistiques suisses datant de 2010
9 environ 5 5% de la population est
musulmane soit un peu plus de quatre
cent mille personnes
on est resté avec mon dans quelques
instants nous reviendrons sur la
situation sanitaire les hôpitaux d'île
de france doivent des programmes et 40%
de leurs activités et ce afin
d'augmenter de 500 places le nombre de
lits de réanimation dédiée aux malades
du code vide
et puis nous parlerons et des 200
enseignants visé par des accusations
d'islamophobie à l'institut d'études
politiques de grenoble
ils sont sous protection annonce gérald
darmanin
[Musique]
avec les accords d'abraham le président
américain reconnaît la souveraineté du
maroc sur le sahara fuyant la france
comme l'europe a été absente de
l'ensemble de cette négociation qui
impactent directement deux pays dans
lesquels nous avons des liens
privilégiés depuis fort longtemps la
république algérienne et le royaume du
maroc des algériens évidemment
mécontents considère la décision
américaine comme une ingérence dans un
problème interne
le maroc a toujours été considérée comme
une menace politique économique et
militaire
face à cette situation conflictuelle
entre les deux pays la france aurait
ainsi l'occasion de participer à la
construction d'un maghreb pacifiées
[Musique]
l'actualité hervé morin c'est évidemment
la crise sanitaire ce que je défends
c'est bien sûr la territorialisation de
la gestion de l'épidémie a voit bien qu
un système centralisé bureaucratique tel
que celui ci a produit toute une série
de dysfonctionnements pas masquer dans
un premier temps pas de test dans un
second temps puis désormais une
insuffisance de vaccins on a senti que
vous étiez nerveux et agacé à l'encontre
de la politique de l'exécutif quant à au
déploiement de la vaccination que je
constate c'est que l'on est le 36e pays
en matière de vaccination
bon ça prouve à quel point on a un
système efficace
en normandie on aura deux usines qui
bientôt produiront des vaccins qui pour
la va être bientôt autorisés sur le
marché compte tenu de la faiblesse de la
vaccination je vois pas comment dans
quatre à six semaines
on pourrait se retrouver libéré
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous insistez beaucoup sur l'aspect des
dépenses publiques ce que je critique
c'est que on est dans un état
d'addiction de grande dépendance à la
dépense publique je ne veux pas du sang
et des larmes le son et les dames on les
a déjà trop de dépenses trop d'état je
pense en tout cas qu'il ya trop de
bureaucratie c'est à dire un état
inefficace tout ça a été financée
essentiellement par de la dette
le problème est moins la dette en
réalité moi je pense qu'on remboursera
la dette par la croissance donc il faut
essayer de libérer l'économie française
et notamment le travail
notre problème en france c'est un
problème où la dépense publique est
excessive
mais surtout elle n'est pas productive
les français n'en ont pas pour leur
argent
de ce point de vue à emmanuel macron n'a
rien changé par exemple par rapport à
son prédécesseur françois hollande
[Musique]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons
la liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même il
n'y a pas une façon plus une pauvre de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez comme moi qui ai des gandhi il n'y
a pas d'alternative au sort du politique
il est clair que tout le monde attend
saft est ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
déçu livre l'uniforme c'est quand même
des hommes comment ces mecs-là arrive à
dormir la nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a
vécu quelque chose d'inné gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
les gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui
le droit on doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas une
république parlementaire
ça se passe en direct puisqu'on est
temps de dire est qu'il y a quand même
la liberté
je vous remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
il ya à peu près un enfant sur deux en
france qui est soit victime soit hauteur
de cyber violent sur internet un contenu
haineux de quelqu'un qui dit à une
fillette de 8 ans on va te suicider ça
ça doit être retirée immédiatement il
n'ya aucun débat à avoir sur son retrait
là parce que ça ça fait des suicides la
loi le condamne déjà c'est déjà interdit
de faire ça bien sûr mais c'est juste
que le légat fall ne l'appliquent pas la
justice est lente et c'est très
problématique qui doit prendre ce rôle
de régulateur la loi peut aider
l'éducation peut aider selon les
différentes catégories d'attaquants et
d'attaquer une erreur de la loi via ça a
été de tout mettre dans le même panier
sous le sous le nom et no line quel rôle
pour les réseaux sociaux on a vu et big
for donc les gaffes à s'organiser pour
annuler quelqu'un sur internet sur
quelqu'un c'était donald trump quand il
s'agit d'un bannissement si général pour
moi ce n'est pas aux gaffes à et aux
réseaux sociaux à dont la des
entreprises privées de prendre cette
décision mais ça doit être à la justice
de prendre cette décision
[Musique]
chaque jour en politique des milliers de
parties d'échecs sont joués mais les
règles ne sont pas toujours respectées
les couleurs changent de camp les pions
prennent la place des rois de fine
stratégie peut porter des résultats
inattendus
un coup décisif ne fait que repousser la
victoire je suis allée de chômeurs et
chaque semaine dans l'échiquier mondial
nous analyserons les coups les plus
complexes du jeu politique
internationale
[Musique]
à bientôt sur rt france on vit tous les
jours sans faire attention que tout en
dépend c'est l'unité de mesure de toute
chose une convention admise par tous
s'il arrive quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
21h heure de paris soyez les bienvenus
en direct sur rt france tout de suite
voici les titres de l'actualité de ce
lundi 8 mars les hôpitaux d'île de
france doit des programmes et 40 % de
leur activité une demande de l'agencé
régionale de santé afin d'augmenter de
500 places le nom de l'hydre animation
dédiée aux malades du code vide
sur le front des vaccins les livraisons
donné en priorité aux pharmacies cette
semaine au détriment des généralistes
qui crient au scandale
le ciel s'éclaircit au royaume uni les
petits anglais retourne enfin sur les
bancs de l'école outre-rhin certaine
restriction levée depuis aujourd'hui
librairie ni fleuriste et auto écoles
rouvrent leurs portes en israël pays de
plus vacciner c'est presque un retour à
la normale avec un accès au restaurant
et bar grâce à un passeport vers une
enquête ouverte pour injures publiques
en cause des affiches anonyme dans
l'enceinte de sciences po grenoble
l accusé nommément deux professeurs
d'islamophobie alors que les deux
enseignants craignent pour leur sécurité
et celle de leur famille tous deux font
l'objet de mesures de protection
susceptible d'être renforcée alors
peut-on encore parler d' islamophobie en
france nous tenterons répondre à cette
question au sénégal opposant ousman
sonko appelle à une mobilisation
beaucoup plus importante mais pacifique
un rappel qui intervient après que la
justice a donné ordre de le relâcher
sous contrôle judiciaire
son arrestation mercredi dernier avait
engendré une contestation populaire
émaillé de violences qui ont fait au
moins cinq morts
[Musique]
ordre fermée ce matin donné par l'
agence régionale de santé ars ile de
france appelle les hôpitaux et cliniques
francilien a déprogrammé 40% de leurs
activités médicales et chirurgicales
objectif augmenter le nombre de lits de
réanimation en pleine pandémie qu'ovide
le but est d'atteindre 1000 1 557 lit
disponible d'ici la semaine prochaine
alors qu'actuellement 973 malades sont
placées en réanimation dans la région
une situation je cite de sensations très
fortes selon le directeur général de la
rs 1 et autres régiront les autres
france où les habitants du pas de calais
viennent de vivre leur premier week-end
confiné une mesure qui doit durer encore
au moins trois semaines en cause la
forte circulation du coc vider la
pression spital hier croissante dans ce
département
et ce alors que la campagne de
vaccination s'accélère mais pas
suffisamment selon certains françois
fils kevin ch
c'était presque un samedi comme les
autres sur la grand place d'arras et ses
alentours
une situation un peu surprenante alors
que les 1 million cinq cent mille
habitants du département du
pas-de-calais ont vécu le premier de
leurs quatre week-ends confiné de cours
en laisser certains un peu perplexe
là il fait beau donc il ya plein de gens
dehors pourtant on est supposé temps
confinement c'est un peu étonnant mais
donc moi j'ai fait mon attestation
normalement on a une heure donc je vais
pas forcément de traîner je suis moi en
colère c'est juste pas possible quoi par
exemple ce matin je me disais moi je
suis vacciné parce que je suis soit
soignants donc j'ai eu cette chance
d'être vacciné très vite et je me dis je
suis obligé de porter le masque quoi ils
sont obligés d'être confiné alors que je
suis vacciné alors donc voila mon
message c'est vaccinez vous vacciner
vous qu'on puisse sortir de tout ça est
un
et le plus vite possible parce que parce
que tout le monde en a assez
mais le pas de calais est en retard dans
la campagne vaccinale des lenteurs liées
à des contraintes d'approvisionnement
avait d'ailleurs reconnu l' agence
régionale de santé qui assure désormais
que ce retard est comblé tout au long du
week end une campagne coup de poing été
lancée permettant d'écouler les dix
mille doses débloqués par le ministre de
la santé pour le département ce dimanche
olivier ferrand s'est rendu dans un
centre de vaccination à boulogne-sur-mer
où il a été interpellé par le maire
socialiste de la ville frédéric
cuvillier mais je n'ai pas eu de réponse
définitive et ceux qui m'invite à à
poursuivre la demande une demande forte
qui étincelle de peut permettre le
rattrapage de ce départ dans ce
département et dans ma région
boulonnaise du nombre de vaccinations
faut savoir que le département du
pas-de-calais dans koh finco confiné
depuis maintenant quelques jours et le
taux de vaccination étant insuffisant
est important que ce message soit
adressée aux autorités sanitaires c'est
à dire de prioriser les populations qui
sont confinés et de leur permettre
d'avoir enfin accès à ces vaccins qui
n'ont que trop tardé une situation vécue
par de nombreux habitants comme une
injustice
c'est vrai qu'à situation sanitaire
équivalente d'autres départements n'ont
pas eu à connaître ces mesures
privatives de liberté et que c'est une
forme d'incompréhension doublé par cette
sentiment d'injustice de ne pas pouvoir
avoir accès à une vaccination plus
massive et plus efficace il n'y a pas de
dose caché au ministère a assuré olivier
ferrand qui s'est félicité de l'effort
exceptionnel consenti ce week end pour
accélérer les vaccinations sur tout le
territoire français
actuellement moins de 4 millions de
français ont reçu au moins une dose un
nombre encore très loin de l'objectif
des 10 millions de premières injections
pour la mi-avril
mais la campagne de vaccination priorité
donnée aux pharmaciens cette semaine
pour commander les doses une annonce qui
fait suite à l'ouverture de la
vaccination en officine à partir de là
du 15 mars et une décision de la
direction générale de la santé qui
provoque la colère des médecins
généralistes
ils sont obligés de revoir leur
calendrier de vaccination et d'annuler
certains rendez vous déjà pris leur
campagne avait débuté le 25 février
dernier ça devrait donc changer de
cadence pour en parler nous sommes avec
bertrand legrand médecins généralistes
secrétaire général de la confédération
des syndicats médicaux français bonsoir
bertron le grand merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france alors on change
un petit peu de main sur la vaccination
en tout cas temporairement et par la
force des choses la commande je cite un
de la semaine du 8 mars est
exceptionnellement ouverte aux seuls
pharmaciens fait savoir la direction
générale de la santé vous faites partie
des médecins en colère ce soir la colère
c'est un mot un peu faible en fait en
réalité on a déclenché ce week-end la
mobilisation générale des médecins
généralistes dans les centres de
vaccination on à décongeler des doses
qui était prévu pour une nouvelle nos
patients qu'on avait priorisé et on les
a injecté au premier arrivé premier
servi
et maintenant on nous dit que les doses
pour nos patients qu'on avait priorisé
qui en ont besoin pour survivre et pour
éviter de passer en réanimation
cela même ne rompt pas leur droit à leur
vaccination parce qu'on a décrété que
des pharmaciens auraient un flacon
par-ci par-là soi disant aux derniers
mails de la dgs parce que le nombre de
doses service est cette semaine là n'est
pas suffisant pour en servir à chaque
médecin
on nage dans l'ubuesque on va nous
interdire de vacciner des patients à
risque pour vacciner n'importe quelle
passion qui a accès à internet c'est
inacceptable la colère des médecins
généralistes et sans fin sans fin ou
quoi c'est totalement inacceptable
voit nos patients pour qui on a choisi
de faire le vaccin parce qu'on veut les
sauver d'une maladie grave du coc vide
se fait reprendre leur tour par des gens
qui arrivent en centre de vaccination
juste parce qu'ils sont éligibles à ce
qu'a été un problème politique donc on
est en train de faire de la politique
spectacle
au lieu de faire de la médecine c'est
inacceptable bertrand legrand c'est vrai
qu'on a du mal je ne cache pas nous
mêmes pourtant j'ai tenté de lire voilà
les les choses sur la logistique le
calendrier comme comment ça s'est fait
un petit peu au dernier moment parce
qu'on a du mal à imaginer que les
médecins généralistes soient obligés de
décommander de déprogrammer les patients
et que cela tombe aussi soudainement et
biba vous êtes surpris et nous sommes
les premiers surpris
la décongélation des doses de ce
week-end pour l'opération de
communication politique de notre premier
de notre ministre de la santé ne s'est
pas fait en concertation avec les
médecins
on nous a pas demandé le nombre de doses
qu'on ne s'y fait les prendre alors que
ces mêmes doses étaient planifiés et on
a cru à un moment donné que tout à coup
on avait touché à un grand nombre de
doses qu'on était plus en pénurie
et il s'avère en réalité que non nous
avons toujours nous sommes toujours en
pénurie mais qu'on a simplement des
voiliers ces doses pour une opération de
communication politique qui sert de
contre-feu à la preuve il ya une
problématique qui est en france
l'absence de doses
et voilà c'est juste ça et aujourd'hui
nous médecins médecins généralistes on
planifie les vaccinations quinze jours
avant parce que on doit sélectionner nos
patients c'est quelque chose que les
français doivent comprendre on n'a pas
assez de doses pour vacciner toutes les
personnes éligibles donc dans ma liste
de 800 personnes que je devrais vacciner
je sélectionne les 150 plus un risque
que je vais vacciner en premier et après
les suivant et ainsi de suite
hélas ce qu'on dit c'est que le
pharmacien qui n'a aucune connaissance
de la de la suite de cette liste va
vacciner le premier arrivé et donc du
coup le patient qui peut être en
position 400 chez moi va se retrouver
avant le positionnant le patient en
position de ce en quoi donc c'est pas
possible c'est inacceptable c'est
inhumain c'est voilà c'est in éthic
nussa sa botte tout le travail qu'on a
fait en amont
alors dans le même temps il yal
astrazeneca qui ne trouvent pas toujours
preneur on a eu des médecins voilà qui
nous ont expliqué ça sur cette chaîne la
semaine dernière qu'ils avaient de la
strade n'est qu'à et que tout le monde
n'en voulait pas ça ne va pas
nécessairement peut-être s'arranger avec
l'épisode aux autrichiens la suspension
de ce vaccin après deux morts suspectes
liés en tout cas à une injection quel
est votre sentiment là dedans c'est vrai
qu'on semble nager en dans l'absurde
dans cette campagne de vaccination en
permanence à bas la vie le dernier mais
de dgs franchement personne ne pouvait
imaginer une telle absurdité faveau
draps une démission du directeur de la
dgs c'est assez évident aujourd'hui se
dépêtre là dedans pour ce qui est de la
difficulté à placer un vaccin ou un
autre l'intérêt personnel des patients à
risque c'est de se faire vacciner le
plus vite plus importe le vaccin on sait
très bien que n'importe lequel des trois
vaccins a exactement la même le même
bénéfice individuel la difficulté qu'on
a nous en tant que médecin généraliste
c'est d'un point de vue santé publique
ça irait plus vite si on utilisait les
deux vaccins les deux vaccins arm donc
moderna et files or pour atteindre une
immunité collective
mais cette immunité collective on va
l'atteindre aux alentours de septembre
octobre si on a beaucoup de chance donc
là c'est pas la question du moment pour
nos patients pour nos patients la
question c'est de sauver leur peau dans
une troisième vague et c'est l'unique
question donc après quel que soit le
vaccin on va l'utiliser et on a très peu
de refus en réalité on a 33 mille
médecins généralistes sur cinquante
mille médecins généralistes qui se sont
investis dans la vaccination
astrazeneca et on a en trois jours
injecter plus de doses quand trois
semaines de centre de vaccination donc
le vrai rouleau compresseur c'est nous
et on est en train de nous arrêter pour
masquer l'absence de commandes de doses
de médecins de vaccins pour les médecins
généralistes donc la france est en
retard et elle continue son retard
on comprend votre agacement parce que
c'est vrai qu'il ya eu beaucoup de
communication surtout ce week-end
avec les 250000 injection vendredi 200
milles samedi on nous dit que voilà ça
va monter en puissance 3 7 millions
français qui ont reçu au moins une dose
de vaccin on nous dit toujours que c'est
voilà tel ou tel pour cent de plus que
la dernière fois sauf que quand on
regarde les chiffres évidemment à
l'étranger notamment au royaume-uni 1 15
7% des personnes contre 5,6 pour cent de
la population française on communique
beaucoup mais on est tout même parmi les
derniers de la classe
c'est une politique du dernier de la
classe
et c'est une politique qui n'est pas
transparente faut dire les choses comme
elles sont aujourd'hui nous sommes dans
un échec de la vaccination
nos personnes de plus de 75 ans qui
souffre notre cible prioritaire ne sont
même pas majoritairement vacciner alors
même qu avec le noël nombre de doses
90% des anglais été vaccinées à doses à
nombre de doses égale donc quelle que
soit la manière dont on regarde les
choses que ce soit sur la vitesse
d'exécution qui a été bien meilleures en
angleterre que ce soit sur le
pourcentage de patients vaccinés
patients à risque la france a échoué à
tous les niveaux et c'est l'échec de la
rsc l'échec des de la dgs et c'est
l'échec du ministre dont le déploiement
de la vaccination
et tout cela est en train de subir une
opération de communication politique
pour faire porter ça sur des médecins
libéraux qui n'ont strictement rien
demandé là dedans ils ne font que leur
travail
donc c'est vraiment vraiment très
énervant alors au milieu de tout ça en
eau des mots vaccinodromes à
voulais pas le faire mais finalement
fait comme comme les allemands une
petite réaction là dessus aussi
c'est toujours la même c'est on est en
france dont non plus dans une politique
gaulliste de protection des plus faibles
on est dans une politique du premier
arrivé premier servi
c'est le libéralisme que l'on déteste et
même nous en tant que médecin libéral on
déteste ce type de choses là c'est une
chose ou on ne donne pas la priorité aux
personnes qui le nécessitent
on donne la priorité à celui qui a le
temps de prendre son rendez vous sur
internet ou qui a les moyens de le
prendre
ça va pas merci beaucoup en tout cas
bertrand legrand d'avoir été avec nous
nous avoir exprimé votre colère après
donc cette décision des autorités de
transférer en tout cas les vaccins pour
le moment aux pharmaciens
merci à vous aurez ce lundi 8 mars où la
journée internationale pour les droits
des femmes pour l'occasion de nombreux
rassemblements au lieu hier et
aujourd'hui un peu partout en france
à paris un rassemblement était organisé
cet après midi entre port royal et place
de la république à l'appel
d'associations et de collectifs
féministes
un cortège avec pour thème cette année
les premières deux camps vie en
référence à dar es trop vite des manuels
maquereau en 2017
les premiers corps d écouter ces
manifestants il ya la moitié de
l'humanité sur cette planète qui est
maltraité jusqu'à présent on commence un
peu à se bouger mais encore peu que je
suis une mère
j'élève mes enfants seuls que la société
s'en fout que on compte beaucoup sur le
dos des femmes pour faire des choses est
que au final on est moins bien payées
moins bien traitées on vers plus de
violences ont fait violer on
voilà je me sens aussi autant concernés
que les femmes tout simplement et je
pense qu'il faut sortir
pour militer pour donner de la force
parce qu'il faut que ça bouge
s'il n'y a pas beaucoup de choses qui
sont faites et donc partout où on va il
ya des différences des discriminations
des inégalités et en partie pour les
femmes alors c'est pas du tout une
minorité ses 52% de la population
française et je pense 50% la boue place
mondiale voire plus donc il faut que ça
fonctionne manifestement il ya encore
beaucoup à faire et puis il ya le
harcèlement les jeunes femmes les les
vieilles femmes les maltraitances bon il
ya toujours à faire de toute façon c'est
comme ça que si tenté que il ya une
histoire c'est comme ça qu'on avance
il faudra toujours combattre ou que ce
soit où que ce soit pas qu'en france
révolte face de la collégienne qui a
accusé samuel petit l'étudiante a
qualifié à l'automne dernier
d'islamophobe le professeur avant qu'il
ne soit tragiquement assassiné à
conflans sainte honorine
j'ai menti selon la sémantique de la
jeune fille de 13 ans ce matin dans les
colonnes du parisien a avoué lors de sa
mise en examen pour dénonciation
calomnieuse avoir été absente lorsque
samuel patty a présenté à ses élèves et
caricatures du prophète mahomet elle
aurait donc seulement rapporté les faits
exposés par ses camarades et son avocat
maître tabou la estime que la
collégienne a conscience de la gravité
de son mensonge mais selon lui sa
cliente ne saurait être tenu pour
responsable de la mort de l'enseignant
écouter à la certains de ses camarades
qui l'ont demandé de rapporter un an
malaise par rapport à la diffusion de
ces caricatures et elle a eu 7 7 cette
mission elle s'est sentie porté par 7 7
7 ce mandat pour justement développer ce
point de vue qui était en point de vue
mensonges et elle ne connaît pas
l'assaillant elle ne le connaissez pas
jamais en contact avec lui mais c'est
même pas à quoi il ressemble c'est pas
quelqu'un qu'elle qu'elle fréquente
n'est ni de loin ni de près et ça c'est
important de le dire presque on laisse
entendre par moments qu'elle était en
lien avec le bourreau de monsieur pâtit
elle a menti c'est une réalité elle
n'aurait pas dû elle le regrette
amèrement
mais jamais elle n'a encouragé souhaiter
la mort de monsieur pâtit jamais elle
n'a appelé à son massacre et la
décapitation
et ça c'est important de le marteler que
l'opinion publique prennent conscience
que cette fille de 13 ans est
responsable de son mensonge mais n'est
pas coupable de la mort de sa belle
patine très puis le parquet de grenoble
saisi par la direction de l'institut
d'études politiques de grenoble après
que deux professeurs et était accusé
d'islamophobie par d
l'eev gérald darmanin annoncé que les
deux hommes étaient désormais placée
sous protection tandis que la direction
sciences po grenoble a condamné dans un
communiqué ces accusations qui met en
danger l'ensemble des étudiants et le
personnel
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
et alors question peut-on encore parler
d' islamophobie en france pour en parler
nous sommes avec julien houde ou le
conseiller municipal de sens membre du
bureau national du rassemblement
national
bonsoir junien houdoud merci d'être avec
nous vous deviez à l'origine à débattre
voilà avec sa mine bola qui avons qu'un
membre de l'association action contre
l'islamophobie mais finalement on fera
une interwiew en tout cas je vous
remercie d'être en direct avec nous des
fascistes dans nos amphis l'islamophobie
tu vois là ce qui était écrit clairement
un jeudi dernier sur les affiches à
l'entrée du campus affiches sur
lesquelles on pouvait lire le nom de
dodo professeur jean michel blanquer qui
dénonce cet après midi des logiques de
délation public est ce que le ministre
de l'éducation raisons selon vous oui
bien sûr jean michel blanquer a
totalement raison
et je tiens à dire que l'islamophobie tu
dans notre pays c'est vrai ils s'aiment
aux phobies peut tuer
celles et ceux qui sont accusés d'
islamophobie car aujourd'hui c'est le
véritable problème
et moi je tiens vraiment à m'insurger
contre la récupération de ce concept qui
a été monté de toutes pièces qui a été
construit par les islamistes
l'islamophobie est un concept islamistes
pour empêcher toute critique toute
condamnation de l'islam du voile
islamique du burkini du halal dans les
cantines
c'est un concept istan liste est
aujourd'hui qui malheureusement s'est
développé dans la société française que
ce soit à l'université via des syndicats
comme l'unef qui n'en est pas
malheureusement à son coup d'essai
puisque l'unef est sortie totalement on
peut dire du champ républicain depuis
quelques années est sorti du finalement
d'une idéologie de gauche qui était la
sienne pour passer à une de logis islamo
gauchiste que ce soit pour la promotion
du hidjab matin midi et soir pour la
promotion du racialisme est là pour ses
combats pour dénoncer et lens est
carrément les fatwas donc pour
l'islamophobie pour dénoncer ce qu'on
appelle islamophobie donc tout ça c'est
extrêmement grave c'est extrêmement
grave et ça nécessite des pouvoirs
publics du ministère évidemment
l'éducation nationale de tous les
responsables politiques une réponse
extrêmement fermes et extrêmement fermes
pour protéger d'une part les victimes de
ces pressions de ces menaces qui sont
totalement intolérables et pour
ressouder à la fois la communauté
enseignante à la fois la hiérarchie de
l'éducation nationale dans les
établissements scolaires parce que ce
qu'on constate malheureusement c'est que
bien souvent les victimes en cent et
ceux qui sont accusés à tort
d'islamophobie sont aujourd'hui lâché
que ce soit par leur administration ou
par leurs collègues professeurs doute
vous venez d'évoquer la liberté
d'expression regardez ce qu'en pense
danièle obono de la france insoumise
justement elle cite également la liberté
d'expression ce qui menace la liberté
d'expression à l'université ce sont les
politiques autoritaires qui précarisent
stigmatise la recherche la sinistre
vidal d'une totale incompétence face à
la crise terni l'image de la france avec
sa chasse à l'islamo gauchisme
qu'est ce que vous lui répondez jeunes
et en donna à danièle obono danièle
obono évidemment et dans le soutien
c'est l'avocate de c2c relais
islamo-gauchiste racialiste indigéniste
au cas aucune aucune surprise
moi je tiens à rappeler que c'est une
préoccupation aujourd'hui majeurs que la
liberté d'expression
évidemment qu'ils aient des
considérations sociales évidemment
qu'est la précarité des étudiants
aujourd'hui lié à la crise sanitaire
mais aujourd'hui des étudiants et je
dirais la société française dans son
ensemble est confronté malheureusement
un émiettement de la liberté
d'expression car aujourd'hui on voit
bien que quand on ose critiquer l'islam
qui n'est qu'une religion est donc en
droit français qui n'est qu'une opinion
dans le droit français
on peut détester une
lyon on peut détester une opinion
politique idéologique on a tout à fait
le droit on n'a pas le droit de s'en
prendre aux croyants pour leur religion
ça c'est évidemment du racisme c'est
condamnable il faut le condamner avec la
plus grande fermeté
mais en france en tout cas dans notre
législation telles sont nos coutumes
telles sont nos règles de droit on peut
être islamophobe
on peut être cathophobes on peut être
judéophobe voilà ça il faut quand même
le rappeler et il faut sanctuariser ce
principe est là malheureusement
aujourd'hui on voit bien qu'avec des
pressions avec des menaces et des
menaces qui conduisent quelquefois
jusqu'au pire jusqu'à des attentats
islamistes comme l'a subi sa nouvelle
pâte il ya quelques mois quand les
persécutions comme évidemment le subit
actuellement à vue pardonnez moi il n'y
a pas eu d'avancée d'après faire samuel
pâtit c'est quand même un enseignant qui
s'est fait décapiter il n'ya et pourtant
les les affaires continuent on n'a pas
tiré les enseignements de cette tragédie
selon vous malheureusement non visible
le monde n'ont pas tiré tiré les leçons
de cette tragédie qui est un traumatisme
sans précédent et qui aurait dû
réveiller les pouvoirs publics le
gouvernement la société française dans
son ensemble
malheureusement aujourd'hui nous avons
un autre enseignant qui a dû renoncer à
enseigner qui est aujourd'hui sous
protection policière qui est monsieur le
maire à trappes et nous avons la jeune
milla qui est déscolarisé parce qu'elle
a osé et donc critiquer l'islam et on
voit bien qu'il ya deux poids deux
mesures parce qu'aujourd'hui les soi
disant victime d' islamophobie donc se
disent victimes parce qu'on leur
interdit d'aller à la piscine en burqini
se disent victimes parce qu'on leur
interdit de porter le voile intégral se
disent victimes
parce qu'elles n'ont pas du halal à la
cantine de leur école
voilà aujourd'hui mais il ya d'autres
victimes qui elles menacent sont menacés
sont persécutés tout simplement parce
qu'on les taxe de raciste tout
simplement parce qu'on les taxe
d'islamophobe juste parce qu'elles ont
voulu comment dirais-je assumer une
opinion et assumer la liberté
d'expression professeur allemand en
l'occurrence au coeur de cette
affaire à l'origine c'était un d'un
atelier informel de travail dit la
liberté d'expression lui est fortement
menacée une minorité essaie d'imposer sa
loi y compris chez les enseignants
chercheurs
on vous attaque de front si vous osez
dire quelque chose qui nous plaît pas en
particulier sur ce qui concerne l'islam
c'est le tabou on imagine que vous
partagez cette opinion ce sera ma
dernière question
oui bien sûr on peut le constater le
déplorer malheureusement tous les jours
l'idéologie islamiste est un fascisme
c'est un fascisme qui condamne toutes
celles et tous ceux qui ne pensent pas
pareil
voilà et quand cette idéologie sous
couvert de lutter contre le racisme
avec ce concept que ce concept
totalement hypocrite d'islamophobie
empêchent les autres de penser empêche
les autres d'avoir une opinion
différente
évidemment que c'est extrêmement grave
et ça doit gérer un site et les plus
hauts responsables nos gouvernants à se
réveiller d'urgence parce que cette
idéologie l avance elle avance surtout
parce que l'étain et la république ne
cesse de reculer
merci beaucoup julie en dioula on
rappelle encore une fois que ça devait
être un débat avec un membre de
l'association action contre
l'islamophobie qui vous aurait donné la
réplique voilà qui s'est décommandé
quelques minutes avant ce face-à-face
merci avoue julien oudoul rester avec
nous dans quelques instants nous
partirons en israël qui retrouvent un
semblant de vie normale réouverture des
restaurants et des bars grâce à une
campagne de vaccination massive et puis
direction le sénégal l'opposant son
corps lâché dakar sous la protection des
blindés de l'armée
[Musique]
louis saillant est un ex commandos
marine il nous emmène dans les coulisses
de la guerre contre le djihadisme au
sahel l'ennemi l'abord est parfaitement
légitime qu'on parle de djihadistes on
parle de gens qui recrutent des enfants
on parle de gens qui sont d'une barbarie
extrême serre est un terreau qui peut
favoriser l'extension du terrorisme ne
faut pas imaginer qu'il suffit
simplement d'avoir un pays pauvre pour
que l'islam c'est un bien acquis sont
embrigadés ils ont été séduits ils ont
été manipulés et d'autres qui agissent
de manière parfaitement consciente et
lucide je respecterai toujours
l'adversaire même si je méprise
totalement son idéologie comme c'est le
cas pour sega liste
la france oubliée c'est une rencontre
avec ces citoyens qui ne se résignent
pas à la fatalité
on est comme tout le monde la mesure
n'est pas en appartement on est énervé
on a le sentiment qu'il faut à chaque
fois se battre ils vivent parfois au
bord des routes nationales pas forcément
loin de paris mais toujours loin de ceux
qui les dirigent
maj auberge mâcon il passe un tour de
tracteur avec toutes les campagnes il
faut savoir si différentes
ils ont le sentiment d'être des français
de seconde zone comme s'ils étaient
invisibles bas pourrait t'aider quoi un
peu plus aujourd'hui la france oubliée
c'est montrer ce qu'on ne voit jamais
[Musique]
21h30 soyez les bienvenus en direct sur
rt france début de déconfinement à
londres ce matin réouverture des écoles
tout à l'heure au royaume-uni levée
progressive des restrictions sanitaires
orchestrée par le premier ministre
britannique et un relâchement comme
boris johnson veut je cite prudent mais
irréversible selon il sera possible dès
le 29 mars se réunira six à l'extérieur
les ouvertures des pubs restaurants et
magasins non essentiels devrait elle
avoir lieu à la mi avril
des mesures qualifiées d' étape cruciale
pour une sortie de confinement selon le
premier ministre boris johnson
aujourd'hui nous avons pu franchir cette
première étape cruciale de ce que nous
espérons être à ta feuille de route
prudent mais réversibles vers la liberté
d'esprit
nous continuerons sur notre lancée mais
nous devons nous rappeler que le retour
à l'école aura bien sûr un impact sur la
propagation du virus et donc à tout
moment et au fur à mesure que nous
décidons des prochaines étapes
et quand nous les franchirons nous
serons guidés par les données et des
mesures d'assouplissement souvent bien
accueillie par les londoniens écouter
nos enfants sont si heureux c'est génial
aussi bien les parents que les enfants
d'ailleurs et ça fait longtemps qu'on
attend ça et c'est tellement bien pour
la santé mentale des enfants d'être de
retour à l'école pour se sociabiliser
interagir à prendre c'était la meilleure
chose à faire de rouvrir les écoles
ça a été long à venir je suis très
heureuse qu'ils ouvrent à nouveau
ça fait très longtemps que les enfants
souhaitent retourner à l'école l
interaction sociale d'être les uns avec
les autres et l'apprentissage plus à
leur manque c'est vraiment important
qu'ils ouvrent aujourd'hui en allemagne
l'espoir revient avec la levée de
certaines restrictions l'objectif
réussir un déconfinement progressif et
conditionnelles ont fait le point avec
les îles à saraf les allemands respire
dont les régions les infections
hebdomadaires sont inférieurs à 50 cas
pour 100000 habitants
certaines restrictions ont été levées
librairie fleuriste et auto école on
ge a rouvert dans quelques régions les
salles de sport de l'état de hesse ont
aussi été autorisée à rouvrir après
plusieurs mois de fermeture
vous pouvez l'imaginer c'est une journée
incroyable pour nous une belle journée
nous sommes désormais autorisés à ouvrir
nos studios de fitness dans deux états
fédéraux en particulier ici en s
nous sommes tous ravis nous sommes
heureux nous étions enfermés depuis si
longtemps
autre avancée la vente de boîtes
d'autotest dans les supermarchés des
tests anti génie qui s'effectue par
prélèvement nasal à domicile sans
oublier la mise en place dans le pays
deux stations gratuite de tesco vide 19
et bien quand c'est gratuit vous le
faites naturellement plus souvent et
plus facilement mais si cela n'avait pas
été gratuit
si je n'avais aucun symptôme alors je ne
serais pas si sûr de me déplacer
bien sûr qu'on ça ne coûte rien je le
fais à six mois des élections fédérales
angela merkel a ainsi fini par céder un
mécontentement croissant dans l'opinion
publique mais aussi au sein de son
propre gouvernement
la chancelière pourrait finalement
réussir à éviter de ternir la fin de son
mandat les bars et les restaurants
rouvrent leurs portes en israël alors
que le pays avait beaucoup misé sur les
vaccinations le taux de contamination
semble diminuer un allègement des
mesures qui tombe à pic pour benyamin
nétanyahou puisque des législatives sont
prévues dans quelques jours grâce d'aia
retour à l'insouciance pour de nombreux
israéliens manger à la terrasse d'un
restaurant
un plaisir qui se faisait attendre pour
shimon et sa femme venue profiter de
cette réouverture avec des amis les
entreprises de la restauration ont connu
une crise année dernière et je pense que
c'est bien de venir et de faire preuve
de solidarité maintenant qu'on est
autorisé à sortir de chez nous et qu'on
a plus de liberté
c'est important de venir soutenir les
restaurants et d'espérer que les choses
vont se poursuivre dans ce sens là de
manière à ce qu'il y ait une continuité
pour les commerces
c'est très important avec 40% de la
population vaccinée l'état hébreu
revient progressivement à la normale
après un troisième confinement mi
février
mais pas pour tout le monde car il faut
être détenteur du fameux passeport vert
octroyé à pour avoir reçu ces deux doses
de vaccin ou être guéri ducobu de 19
pour les restaurateurs peu importe
l'important n'est pas là lorsque le
restaurant est fermé
les dettes s'accumulent qu'il s'agisse
du loyer des taxes municipales de nos
dépenses quotidiennes aujourd'hui nous
avons rouvert après un an d'inactivité
de chômage nous avons mis nos employés
en congé sans solde puis on les a
rappelés puis on les a remis et
aujourd'hui on les rappelle à nouveau
notre principale préoccupation est sans
faire de politique de savoir s'il y aura
un quatrième et un cinquième confinement
dont il nous sera très très difficile de
nous relever les écoles et les collèges
sont également autorisés à rouvrir dans
les zones les moins touchées du pays
l'aéroport ben gourion de tel aviv
accueillera lui désormais 1000 voyageurs
quotidiens contre 200 il ya quelques
jours
côté contamination les chiffres sont à
la baisse elles étaient au nombre de
trois mille six cents par jour il ya une
semaine contre 10000 à la mi janvier des
chiffres encourageants mais les
responsables de la santé publique
entendent rester prudent si nous
n'agissons pas de façon responsable si
nous ne suivons pas les directives la
possibilité d'un quatrième confinement
avant les élections est réelle mais pour
l'heure benyamin nétanyahou a d'autres
priorités
il compte bien récolter les lauriers de
sa campagne de vaccination massive lors
des élections législatives du 23 mars
les quatrièmes en moins de deux ans et
selon les sondages son parti le likoud
pourrait une fois de plus remporté la
mise même s'il ne semble pas en mesure
de gouverner seul
oui pour en parler non chargeant des
règles depuis tel aviv avec paula slayer
journalistes pour rt internationale
c'est notre rubrique vu de l'extérieur
[Musique]
bonsoir paula slayer merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france alors en
israël est ce qu'on peut parler de quasi
retour à la normale faites nous rêver
paula il aimait ce nouveau missile plus
haut niveau de normalité que nous ayons
commune depuis pas mal de temps les
centres commerciaux les centres sportifs
les hôtels sont ouverts notamment pour
les personnes qui ont reçu deux doses de
vaccin et ont obtenu ce qu'on appelle un
passeport vert il t'a bien que se rendre
mais ils veulent
en parallèle nous avons vu aujourd'hui
la 5000ème personne à être vaccinés dans
un pays de 9 millions d'habitants
donc il reste six heures à peine plus
d'un million de personnes de plus de 16
ans a vacciné et le premier ministre
benjamin netanyahu
jbe maxime et promet que ces derniers
réunion sera vacciné avant le 8 avril
d'après le premier ministre il fait
également y avoir des usines construites
sur le sol australien pour produire des
vaccins à l'avenir ce passeport vert
serait valable pour les six prochains
mois donc il semble y avoir un consensus
en israël que c'est une solution à court
terme et qu'il faudra avoir des seins
revaccination des rappels le pays a été
divisé en couleur dans les régions non
qualifiés de weert les écoles ni moore
ouvert et on essaye de rendre le pays
aussi vert que possible on entendait
dans cet émoi hier jeudi revoilà
a possiblement une quatrième vague qui
pourrait arriver un quatrième
confinement en tout cas plutôt ça veut
dire qu'on vit vous plus normalement
qu'avant vous vous avez très bien
expliqués mais avec énormément de
prudence on sent que ça peut basculer
d'un instant à l'autre malgré ces
vaccinations les trouver c'est correct
malgré la vaccination explique toujours
aux gens qu'il faut porter le masque qui
est obligatoire et respecter la distance
de marche de socialisation et j'ai pensé
pendant ses cours de l'année passée car
l'économie a réouvert complètement mais
j'ai fait le dimanche n'est pas un
retour complet à la normale car les gens
portent toujours des masques et
certaines personnes ne souhaitent pas
être vaccinés les personne d'ailleurs ne
souhaitant pas être vaccinés sont sous
pression pour recevoir le vaccin mais
ont un choix elles peuvent tous les
trois jours toutes les 70 heures être
testés et recevoir à ousse un document
certifiant qu'elle sont négatifs
avec ce papier elles doivent seront
ressemble tout de même mieux que les
personnes vaccinées mais elles devront
rester en terrasse par exemple au
restaurant ou prier à l'extérieur deux
synagogues ou d'autres lieux de culte
j'ai eu beaucoup donnent une campagne
sur facebook inciter les personnes qui
ne croyaient pas au vaccin à s'inscrire
pour une vaccination sans se rendre au
rendez vous j'ai parlé à des gens qui
m'ont confirmé avoir été sous pression
de se faire vacciner
le pays et c'est effectivement de
retourner à la normale il faut également
savoir qu'on a de soi disant que les
personnes vaccinées serait risqué et ses
listes de transmis aux autorités mais on
essaye d'encadrer la situation pour
qu'on ne puisse pas être utilisé pour
d'autres moyens on l'entendait dans le
sujet tout à l'heure en de nouvelles
élections on le sait un national dans
dans quinze jours ce sont
des allègements qui arrive à un très bon
moment on imagine pour le premier
ministre netanyahu
c'est de bon augure quels sont les
sondages pour lui ça se ressent
j'imagine sur la popularité
effectivement cela se reflète dans sa
popularité il appartient au parti du
trou d'air frais et après les élections
sondage récemment pour les élections qui
auront lieu le 23 mars à lui de rappeler
qu en très bonne position au départ il
était mort il n'a pas assez dur sièges
pour pouvoir former une majorité attend
pas et ce qu'ils sont et un siège pour
les journées sans aucun doute une
nouvelle je le comprends au nouveau
gouvernement de coalition et où devra
trouver des alliés mais la population et
aucune n'est pas enthousiaste c'est la
4ème élections en deux ans donc les
israéliens en août assez de surveillants
avaient voté dans le même temps les
sondages indiquent que 62 % des
israéliens et 16 % des israéliens disent
qu'ils ne voteront pas gagner mille
éclats niari mais qui dans le cadre de
sa campagne électorale
je découpe sur le programme de
vaccination anti cofield et il s'attarde
le crédit du déploiement extrêmement du
pacs mais rapide déploiement de la
vaccination si mu likoud parti il deux
parties il jouit de kesa fraîchement le
cd accents de la tv comme levier de
communication majeure non mais qui
dernièrement les sujets de conversation
se sont tournés vers l'économie en d3
me montagne ou de colonnes qui a
réouvert les collèges donc effectivement
l'aco vide est un thème électoral alors
l'état hébreu qui a lancé officiellement
aujourd'hui la campagne de vaccination
des palestiniens qui travaillent en
israël ou dans les colonies en
cisjordanie occupée
à quoi doit-on sa face à la pression des
ong
hier que nous valons de savalou
travailleurs palestiniens colonies en
cisjordanie en israël le début de cette
campagne de vaccination a été repoussée
gens pour des raisons techniques les
israéliens pour pouvoir vacciner a
vaincu pas brillé de personnes par jouer
les groupes de défense des droits de
l'homme débat sur la responsabilité
d'israël concernant la vaccination des
palestiniens non seulement des
travailleurs mais des palestiniens en
général parce que les travailleurs
palestiniens se sont effectivement en
contact très proche avec les israéliens
philippe brégi quelques il serait
prennent en charge la vaccination mais
certains groupes disent qu'israël de
faire vacciner tous les palestiniens
il existe des contraintes vertu des
règles internationales
il s'agit d une puissance occupante mais
les israéliens disent qu'ils sont pas
une puissance occupante qui ne sont pas
responsables
les travailleurs il sera dans les
colonies en cisjordanie un côté bâtiment
la plupart des palestiniens en
cisjordanie ou dans la bande de gaza
n'ont pas été vaccinés écouler les
vaccins sont régis par exemple de russie
mais cependant ces bassins ont été
accaparées par lolita et la majorité des
palestiniens n'ont pas vu le moindre
versant c'est la situation actuelle et
l'on m'entende et rapporter droits que
les associations de défense des droits
de l'homme
il doit y avoir plus d'élan vers la
vaccination
il n'est pas clair un nouveau seuil de
25 du fait et quand la vaccination a
commencé dans les territoires
palestiniens d'ampleur merci pour l'unss
ailleurs j'en ai espoir très
internationale d'avoir été avec nous
pour vu de l'extérieur ce soir en direct
d'israël merci à vous 1 1-10 agitée à
dakar des centaines de manifestants ont
célébré la libération d'opposants ousman
sonko elle le rival du président macky
sall arrêté pour trouble à l'ordre
public puis relâchés mais inculpé dans
une affaire de viol l'opposition appelle
à continuer de protester ces prochains
jours alors que les forces de l'ordre
sont toujours présentes au coeur de la
capitale sénégalaise où habitent des
nani une marche pour la liberté
l'un des avocats d'ousmane sonko demande
à l'afutt de se calmer les supporters de
l'opposant numéro un au président macky
sall est euphorique après la dernière
décision de justice où ce match son
cours en garde à vue depuis mercredi 3
mars et donc relâché sous contrôle
judiciaire
un soulagement pour son équipe alors que
le député est à nouveau inculpé ce lundi
pour une affaire de viol présumé et de
menaces de mort sur une employée de
salons de massage maintenant une
révolution au fond et qui permettra de
révéler si oui ou non il ya eu viol ou
aux menaces de mort son arrestation la
semaine dernière pour trouble à l'ordre
public alors qu'il se rendait au
tribunal pour répondre à sa convocation
judiciaire avait déclenché un
soulèvement d'une partie de la
population
trois jours d'émeutes d'affrontements
avec les forces de l'ordre des enseignes
france est également ciblée
dans la foulée un mouvement est né celui
de la défense de la démocratie
composé d'associations de la société
civile et des partis politiques de
l'opposition
un appel à manifester jusqu'à mercredi a
été lancé ousman sonko déclaré lundi
soir espérer une mobilisation beaucoup
plus importante mais pacifique
ce n'est pas normal c'est de la
dictature et nous nous sommes battus
nous nous sommes battus peut être leed
nous nous sommes battus nous nous sommes
battus pour que les fils et les filles
du sénégal puisse vivre dans un pays
libre par 15 m à la ville pour faire ici
on n'a pas de travail n'est rien par
rapport à nos enfants est pas moi moi à
58 en dessinant twitter je préfère
encore à elle seule dénonciation d'un
complot politique contestation sociale
en temps de crise économique et
sanitaire la jeunesse sénégalaise et
l'opposition cible le président macky
sall sorti du silence lundi soir
j'engagerai dans les meilleurs délais
une réorientation des allocations
budgétaires pour améliorer de façon
substantielle urgente les réponses aux
besoins des jeunes en termes de
formation d'emploi de financement de
projets de soutien à l'entrepreneuriat
au secteur informel j'ai décidé
d'alléger le couvre feu lié à l'état de
catastrophe sanitaire dans les régions
de dakar et de thiès qui cela désormais
fixé de minuit à 5 heures du matin
j'invite toutes les forces vives de la
nation à l'apaisement la sécurité a été
renforcée autour du palais présidentiel
lundi en fin d'après midi la police anti
émeute a de nouveau disperser la foule
utilisant gaz lacrymogène et bombes
assourdissantes
plusieurs enseignes françaises ont été
la cible entre autres de pillage nous
aller la voir sur ces images à dakar un
commerce a été vandalisée lors de heurts
la semaine passée au moins une dizaine
talisman a subi le même sort la france
est accusée par certains manifestants de
soutenir le président macky sall mais
ces pièges cause du tort aux sénégalais
qui subissent déjà les conséquences
économiques de la faune des nus ce qui
s'est passé à ce moment là c'est
alarmant tour parce que c'est nous les
sénégalais qui travaillent ici c'est
parler france d'accord les français sont
là ils sont venus sont investis ils ont
menti ils ont eu un effet ciseau mais le
hasard mais ce qui se passe ici c'est
une catastrophe
c'est une catastrophe c'est pas le fait
d'un vent fort il ya des malfaiteurs qui
elle filtre les gens qui poussent les
jeunes à faire du bordel dans le pays ça
et ça ça fait pas avancer sans égal ça
c'est dit c'est pas ça quand tu vas dans
les grandes nations tu tues tu vas pas
ça
et pour en parler nous sommes à becker
louis keumayou président du club de
l'information africaine bonsoir louis
keumayou merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france alors l'arrestation
de l'opposant sont co la semaine
dernière pour des accusations de viol
est ce qu'elle est finalement lui là la
principale raison de ce soulèvement
populaire où il y a un lien avec sa cote
de popularité
je pense que la faire son cours va au
delà de tout ce que nous vivons
aujourd'hui je pense que c'est l'élément
détonateur d'une colère d'une décennie
au maquis shell faut jamais oublier que
pour le deuxième mandat
le scénario que nous vivons aujourd'hui
avait déjà été définis avec
l'arrestation de khalifa sall qui avait
été mis hors de course parce qu'il avait
une affaire judiciaire que son immunité
parlementaire avait été levée et qu'il
n'avait pas plu compétir pour la
présidentielle nous en sommes à peu près
au même stade aujourd'hui même si on
trouve des montagnes juridiquement pas
possible pour mathis l on en est à un
stade où on prépare déjà la prochaine
présidentielle
et donc on semaine son projet en quelque
sorte à travers son affaire symbolise le
ras-le-bol que les sénégalais ont la foi
de sentir que lors de nos gestes et en
recul de sentir que la vie politique est
aujourd'hui presque privatives et par un
club et cette privatisation profite au
président en place
donc ce sont tous ces éléments-là ajouté
à la pauvreté de plus en plus galopante
et la crise
qui font que la sphère son côté plus un
détonateur que l'afer a en elle même
normalement tout en politique n'est pas
du sud la loi donc s'il doit répondre du
fait d'être il faut qu'ils répondent
devant la justice
mais quand la justice est
instrumentalisée pomme les gens semblent
le penser à dakar
ça pose un problème il en est face à ce
problème est-ce qu'on peut s'inquiéter
d'une tournure autoritaire de la part du
président macky sall je pense que la
tournure autorités régulatrices depuis
déjà plusieurs années
on l'a vu quand il a commencé à on doit
faire de la bonne gouvernance en
attaquant le fils karim wade qui l'a
mise en prison qu'il a jugée à travers
un tribunal spécial sur lequel il n'y a
pas de possibilité d'appel
par jugement rendu on a vu également
avec la leaf rethel il ya eu d'autres
cas de figure et santé et dans laquelle
on ne peut pas dire que la justice était
complètement indépendante vis-à-vis du
pouvoir exécutif
donc c'est vrai qu'il ya une livrée et
rire de la part du président sénégalais
ou de l'exécutif sénégalais et qui n'est
pas bon signe point click était
présentée depuis plusieurs années comme
une vitrine de la démocratie en afrique
francophone en afrique tout court alors
plusieurs enseignes françaises ont été
la cible de pillages dans les
manifestants accusent la france de
soutenir le président saleh ce que c'est
le cas c'est un mauvais procès qui est
fait à la france il ya des entreprises
sera fait sur place qui gagne les
marchés qui les gagnent dans des
conditions pas qu'ils jouent très
orthodoxe mais je pense que le
patriotisme en faveur de l'économie
sénégalaise n'est pas un patriotisme qui
devrait être contre les intérêts 107 ya
cette histoire du froid soufre qui
traîne depuis de nombreuses années la
france a dit qu'elle a arrêté
aujourd'hui avec le jeu de leconte pied
à l'entrée leur public français qui
permet d'avoir des réserves pour les
états africains que s'il devait
remplacer le français 109e qui tarde
encore à se réaliser
matérialiser sur le terrain en raison de
la crise sanitaire
il écoute devrait déjà être un tribut à
la crise de gaza que le calendrier a
pris du retard
quel que soit aujourd'hui les
revendications qui sont sur la place
instrumentaliser la violence politique
en direction de la france est de mon
point de vue être la solution
il ya de vrais problèmes politiques il
ya un vrai problème de transparence de
gouvernance mais cela ne devrait pas se
résumer à lui elle dit française c'est
un autre problème
on est surtout passé tu as un autre
registre aujourd'hui merci beaucoup lui
que mes yeux nous avoir apporté votre
analyse en direct de lomé au togo pour
évoquer donc la situation du sénégal
merci à vous et c'est la fin de cette
émission merci d'avoir suivi prochain
pas complet ce sera dans quelques
minutes avec pierre qui savent hivernaux
quant à moi j'aurai le plaisir de vous
retrouver demain à 20 heures
[Musique]
vous êtes né dans la musique vous êtes
né dans une famille d'artistes désir
révélée brutalement par la prise de
conscience du concert symphonique qui
m'a donné envie d'être chef d'orchestre
ça a balayé tout le reste c'est un acte
d'amour la musique pour vous un oui mais
l'art en général vous savez ça permet de
mieux se connaître ça permet de mieux
partager